"THE FIVE"."
♪ ♪
THIS MORNING, MORE HAIR WAS ON
FIRE THAN THE FORESTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
>> THIS WAS THE MOST CHAOTIC
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE OF EVER
SEEN.
>> THAT WAS A HOT MESS INSIDE A
DUMPSTER FIRE INSIDE A
TRAIN WRECK.
THAT WAS THE WORST DEBATE I HAVE
EVER SEEN.
>> THAT WAS [BLEEP].
>> IT WAS A COMPLETE DISASTER.
>> THAT WAS THE WORST
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE I’VE EVER
SEEN IN MY LIFE.
>> THIS FELT LIKE AN ASSAULT.
IT FELT LIKE AN ASSAULT ON OUR
SENSES, AN ASSAULT ON HER
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN PROCESS.
WE’VE GOT 2 MINUTES?
FORGET THAT, I’M TALKING OVER
YOU.
>> OH, BOY.
MY RESPONSE?
WHAT DID YOU EXPECT?
FROM THE MEDIA OR THE DEBATE?
IF YOU WERE HOPING FOR
LINCOLN-DOUGLAS, YOU DESERVE
LINCOLN LOGS.
BUT THE MEDIA IS JUST PERFORMING
THE SCRIPT, REACTING AS IF TRUMP
CARPET BOMBED CANADA BECAUSE HE
WOULDN’T PLAY NICE TO JOE AND
BECAUSE JOE SEEMS SO
OVERWHELMED, BUT THIS IS WHAT
THEY DO ANY TIME TRUMP HIS FACE.
THE ONLY THING THE MEDIA HATES
MORE THAN TRUMP IS TRUMP ’SPACE.
BUT I HAD IT WORSE.
I HAD TO WATCH THE DEBATE WITH
JASPER.
WHILE DANA WAS PARTYING IN OHIO,
I HAD 90 POUNDS OF DOG WRAPPING
UP THE MIKE RUBBING UP AGAINST
MY HIP.
>> AND YOU LOVED IT.
>> I DID.
BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS A GREAT
EVENING.
>> IT WAS A GREAT EVENING, AN
EXCITING EVENING.
BY EVERY MEASURE WE WON THE
DEBATE EASILY LAST NIGHT.
I THINK IS VERY WEAK, I DON’T
MIND DEBATING HIM.
I HEAR HE WANTS TO GET OUT OF
THE DEBATES.
>> HERE’S WHY LAST NIGHT WAS SO
ODD.
IN A FORMAL DEBATE, THE TOPIC IS
AND TO THE DEBATERS THEMSELVES,
IT’S A TOPIC WITH NUCLEAR POWER,
PEACE IN THE MIDDLE EAST, OR
SHOULD JESSE LOSE THE HAIRPIECE?
THE LAST NIGHT BIDEN SKIPPED ALL
OF HIS BIG PLANS AND MADE TRUMP
THE SOLE TOPIC, THAT HE’S A VERY
BAD MAN, A RACIST, MAY BE A
KILLER.
ALL PERSONAL, NO POLICY.
THAT SUITS HIS BASE BUT WINNING
NO CONVERTS, WHICH LED TO THIS.
>> BECAUSE YOU ARE A PRESIDENT
SCREWING THINGS UP.
YOU ARE THE WORST PRESIDENT
AMERICA HAS EVER HAD.
>> THE QUESTION IS --
>> RADICAL LEFT.
>> WILL YOU SHUT UP, MAN?
>> HE GOT VERY LUCKY.
THERE IS NOTHING SMART ABOUT
YOU, JOE.
>> IT’S HARD TO GET ANY WORD IN
WHAT THIS CLOWN.
>> TRUMP INTERRUPTED BECAUSE HE
WAS LETTING HIM FILL IN A SENSE
OF TRUMP LOOKS RUDE BUT WHAT
WERE HIS CHOICES?
THERE WAS NO ROOM FOR A BOTTLE
AND WITH THE STRUCTURE, NO
REPOT, YOU INTERRUPT.
SO TRUMP INTERRUPTED MORE AND
WAS SCOLDED FOR IT AS IF JOE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES WHEN HE
WAS JUST SLINGING MUD.
NOW WE SEE THE ENABLING MEDIA
CIRCLING THE WAGONS AROUND JOE.
>> I DON’T THINK THE COUNTRY IS
GOING TO BE YEARNING FOR ANOTHER
ONE OF THESE.
I THINK THAT BIDEN HAS A
DECISION TO MAKE.
>> THERE SHOULD BE A PENALTY FOR
THE FLOUTING OF THE ROLES AND IF
TRUMP DOESN’T WANT TO AGREE TO
THAT, THEN WE DON’T HAVE TO HAVE
ANYMORE DEBATES DEBATES.
>> WE CAN’T DO TWO MORE OF
THESE.
>> THE ELECTION IS FAR TOO
IMPORTANT.
THIS DECISION IN THIS YEAR IS
TOO IMPORTANT TO DO THAT TWO
MORE TIMES.
>> OH, MY WORD.
IF WE ARE DEBT THE MEDIA WANTS
LESS INFORMATION, LESS
TRANSPARENCY, FEWER DEBATES, WHY
WOULD THEY DEPRIVE AMERICA OF
THAT?
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
THAT THEY TRULY DO HAVE A DOG IN
THIS RACE AND IT AIN’T JASPER,
IT’S A MOTT THAT THEY FEAR ISN’T
GOING TO MAKE IT TO THE FINISH
LINE.
I HAD TO WORK JASPER IN THERE.
I WANT TO GO TO JESSE FIRST
BECAUSE YOU TOLD ME LIKE A LOT
OF PEOPLE, THEY WATCHED IT
TWICE.
>> I DID, I WATCHED IT AGAIN ON
YOUTUBE THIS MORNING IN A CALM
OR, PEACEFUL SETTING.
AND IT’S A LOT DIFFERENT.
TRUMP CRUSHED HIM ON THE
REWATCH.
HE WASN’T AS RUDE AS A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE SAYING AND
JOE BIDEN’S JOB WAS TO DEFEND
HIMSELF AND HE DIDN’T DO A VERY
GOOD JOB OF THAT.
THESE GUYS WERE ON A CORROSION
DOME A COLLISION COURSE FOR OVER
A YEAR WE EXPECTED A SPECTACLE
SO I DON’T KNOW WHY EVERYBODY IS
ACTING LIKE THIS WAS THAT BIG OF
A DEAL.
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT HAVE THE
MENTAL ACUITY OR THE VERBAL
TENACITY TO STAND IN THE RING
AND THROW PUNCHES WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
HE WAS VERY DEFENSIVE LAST
NIGHT, HE WAS CONSTANTLY BEING
INTERRUPTED AN ACCOUNT OF THE
PUNCHES, TRUMP THREW MORE
PUNCHES, HE LANDED MORE PUNCHES
AND IF JOE THE ENTIRE TIME IS
JUST SAYING THAT’S WRONG, THAT
DIDN’T HAPPEN, THAT’S NOT TRUE,
THAT’S NOT DEBATING, THAT’S JUST
DENYING AND IF THE MEDIA IS OUT
THERE THE NEXT DAY SAYING WE
SHOULD CANCEL THE REST OF THE
DEBATES, THAT MEANS JOE BIDEN
LOST.
AND THE DEMOCRATS DON’T THINK
JOE BIDEN WON BECAUSE I GOT A
LOT OF TEXTS FROM MOM, AND TRUST
ME, JOE BIDEN DID NOT WIN THAT
DEBATE.
>> JOE BIDEN DID NOT LOOK LIKE
HE HAD ANY COLOR IN HIS FACE, IN
HIS HAIR, HIS MOUTH HUNG AGAPE
MOST OF THE TIME AND SEEMED
EXASPERATED TO ME.
IF DONALD TRUMP WOULD DO ONE
THING BETTER, THIS WOULD BE MY
ADVICE.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU THROW A PUNCH?
COME BACK AND JUST PAUSE FOR A
BEAT OR TWO.
LET IT MARINATE.
THE ONE TIME HE SAID HEY, CAN
YOU NAME ONE LAW-ENFORCEMENT
GROUP GROUP THAT ACTUALLY
ENDORSED YOU?
JUST SIT THERE, TAKE A MOMENT,
LET IT BREATHE BECAUSE THOSE
MOMENTS YOU REALLY HAVE TO
ACCENTUATE.
JOE I THOUGHT FAILED THE
LEADERSHIP TEST ON THE NUMBER OF
ISSUES.
HE WAS ASKED DID YOU EVER CALL
THE LEADER OF PORTLAND?
HE NEVER EVEN CALLED THEM.
HE SAID ANTIFA WAS AN IDEA.
I’VE NEVER SEEN AN IDEA LIKE SO
MANY FIRES.
AND THEN WHEN HE WAS SAYING, YOU
KNOW, YOU HAVE THE CHINESE, THE
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIAN
BILLIONAIRES SENDING LOADS OF
MONEY TO YOUR FAMILY, HE
COULDN’T EVEN EXPLAIN WHY THAT
WAS HAPPENING.
SO THE PRESIDENT WENT OUT, WAS
VERY STRONG HIT, HE ACTUALLY
ASKED JOE A DIRECT QUESTION.
JOE DID NOT ANSWER A DIRECT
QUESTION FROM THE MODERATOR OR
THE PRESIDENT AND HE WAS VERY
STRONG ONLINE ORDER AND THE
ECONOMY.
>> SO DANA, DID YOU WATCH IT
TWICE?
>> I WATCHED IT ONCE LIVE IN A
LISTEN TO IT THIS MORNING.
>> THAT’S GOT TO BE DIFFERENT.
>> IT WAS.
I’M NOT GOING TO SAY IT WAS
NECESSARILY BETTER THE SECOND
TIME AROUND, ALTHOUGH I WAS MORE
COMFY AND I GOT TO LISTEN TO IT
WITH JASPER THIS MORNING.
I AGREE WITH YOU, JESSIE.
THE WORST THING THAT YOU CAN DO
FOR JOE BIDEN IS GIVE HIM THE
FLOOR.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP NEVER LET
THEM HAVE THE FLOOR.
>> ESPECIALLY WITH THE GREEN NEW
DEAL THING.
>> THE OTHER THING I WAS READING
A LOT OF IT TODAY AS WELL, IF
YOU READ SOME OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S LINES, THEY
ARE VERY GOOD.
HIS STUFF ON THE ENVIRONMENT WAS
EXCELLENT.
LAW AND ORDER WAS VERY GOOD.
I’VE DONE MORE IN 47 MONTHS THAT
YOU’VE DONE 47 YEARS BUT I GOT
TO TELL YOU, REMEMBER WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED "THE FIVE" AND WE
GOT IN TROUBLE BECAUSE WE WERE
ALWAYS TALKING ALL AT ONCE YOU
MAKE WHEN YOU LISTEN TO IT, IT’S
VERY HARD.
HERE’S THE OTHER THINGS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S VOICE CARRIES.
IT PENETRATES, IT IS MUCH MORE
POWERFUL THAN JOE BIDEN’S.
SO WHATEVER PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
INTERJECTING, IT WAS COMING FOR
MORE -- IF YOU LISTEN, BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN IS TRYING TO GET IN
THERE AS WELL, BUT NOT
PENETRATING.
>> BECAUSE HE’S WEAK.
I AGREE WITH YOU, DANA, HE’S
VERY WEAK.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE WRITTEN
LINES -- BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE HAVE THE DEBATE, THERE ARE
GOING TO BE MORE DEBATES.
I’M LOOKING FORWARD TO PENS AND
KAMALA HARRIS, THOSE ARE TWO
VERY DIFFERENT STYLES.
>> JUAN, DO YOU THINK THERE’S
GOING TO BE ANOTHER DEBATE?
>> JOE BIDEN SAID TODAY HE WILL
ALWAYS LOOK FORWARD -- I THINK
THAT’S A LOT OF MEDIA.
LET’S MAKE GREAT SOMETHING,
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH AN AWFUL
DEBATE.
I’M LISTENING TO YOU GUYS AND I
AM LIKE -- YOU KNOW, WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE MEDIA, YOU WANT TO
FOCUS ON JOE BIDEN.
WHAT ABOUT THE AWFUL RUDE, CRUDE
BEHAVIOR AND LIES TOLD BY
DONALD TRUMP?
LET’S LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT’S
OWN WORDS.
BRIAN KILMEADE SAID THIS WAS A
LAYUP.
CONDEMN WHITE SUPREMACY.
WHAT DID HE SAY?
HE FELT IT.
HE COULDN’T MAKE A LAYUP.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE SAID INSTEAD?
YOU KNOW WHAT, I’M NOT SURE,
WHAT’S THIS PROUD BOYS -- AND
THEN HE SAID -- LET ME FINISH!
HERE’S THE QUOTE.
STAND BACK, STAND BY.
THE PROUD BOYS TODAY HAVE MADE
NAMES, LOGOS, T-SHIRTS, SO THE
WHITE SUPREMACISTS GOT IT.
NOW TRUMP CAME BACK TODAY, HE
TRIED TO HALF-HEARTED CLEANUP.
THIS IS AFTER A DAY IS TRYING TO
HALF-HEARTED CLEANUP ON THE WAY
TO THE HELICOPTER AND HE SAYS,
WELL, I DON’T WANT TO --
>> PARAPHRASE END.
>> SENATOR McCONNELL,
SENATOR SCOTT, HIS BIG ALLIES,
EVERY REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR
SENATE IN THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN
ON THE DEFENSIVE ALL DAY TRYING
TO DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
CLOSED HIS EYES AND WINKED,
WINKED AT WHITE SUPREMACY.
AND ONE LESS THING TO YOU -- ONE
LAST THING.
YOU KNOW HOW YOU ALWAYS SAY
PEOPLE DIDN’T UNDERSTAND WHAT HE
SAID ABOUT FLYING PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES IN CHARLOTTESVILLE?
AFTER LAST NIGHT, AFTER LAST
NIGHT, WHAT’S A PREMISES --
>> [INDISCERNIBLE].
>> CONTINUED TO EMBRACE WHAT’S A
PHARMACY.
>> IF THAT’S ALL YOU HAVE UP TO
THE DEBATE, THAT’S NOT MUCH.
>> WHAT’S NOT MUCH AS YOU SIT
THERE AND SAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS [INDISCERNIBLE].
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE!
>> THE PROUD BOYS ARE BURIED
>> KENNEDY, LAST WORD TO YOU.
DID YOU LIKE IT OR DID YOU LOVE
IT?
>> I LOVE IT AND MAYBE FOUR
DIFFERENT REASON.
I LOVE THAT BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT
WAS A GREAT BILLBOARD FOR WHY WE
NEED MULTIPLE PARTIES IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT YOU END UP
WITH.
I THOUGHT BOTH OF THEM -- I
THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT WAS
UNDISCIPLINED.
I THINK YOU WILL WATCH THAT AND
I THINK YOU’RE RIGHT, SOME OF
THE SIGNS WERE REALLY FUNNY.
19 -- WHEN THE DASHED LINES ARE
PEPPERED THROUGHOUT, BUT HE
REALLY SHOULD HAVE LET JOE BIDEN
ANSWER ABOUT PACKING THE COURT
AND WHO IS ON HIS SCOTUS
SHORT-LIST, BECAUSE THOSE ARE
CRITICAL QUESTIONS AND IT’S A
VERY PELOSI THING TO SAY I WILL
TELL YOU AFTER HIM ELECTED.
THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW BEFORE THEY
VOTE FOR YOU.
IT’S DISINGENUOUS TO WITHHOLD
THAT INFORMATION.
WE GOT THE DEBATE WE DESERVE.
AND IT’S LIKE A HEROIN ADDICT
DENOUNCING OPIATES, BECAUSE YOU
GOT IT IN YOUR VEINS NOW AND